okay so we're doing donnie darko right
yes this is the movie retrospective like
i said we just started doing polls over
on patreon so if you're not a patron you
got to go over there and
you can give as little as a dollar a
month and you will be able to
participate in the polls to vote on what
the movie retrospective and the topic is
going to be for the upcoming week
and donnie darko won this week yeah i'd
seen it a long time ago i didn't
understand it then i don't think i still
understand
but i like it it's a good movie it's a
real well-made movie it's got a badass
[ __ ] soundtrack
i love the soundtrack yes i really do i
mean i mean this is like
most of my favorite songs from the 80s
are in this killing moon by the echo and
the body men you know under milky way by
the church
yeah level tears apart yeah there's a
bunch of tears for fear songs in there
one of them is a cover
yeah but yeah you ought to make a
[ __ ] playlist from this movie
yeah run that [ __ ] in the car i have
all the songs
so i'll try music that would be easy
enough to do a church song
yeah i love that actually that whole
album is good it's called starfish it
came out in 1988.
yeah um oh and uh notorious by duran
duran yeah is also in this with
i graduated in sparkle motion dancing i
graduated high school in 87 so all these
songs are like from
me the era of me [ __ ] stepping out
into the world
getting my ass kicked because when you
come out of high school you know what
the [ __ ] you're doing
but there's just something about that
that's 50 and i still don't know what
the [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i'll start to understand i was doing
about 40 38 39
40 around that time but i still feel
like i'm faking it all the time no this
is the real deal this is the real deal
this is how it is
but uh now that that [ __ ] soundtrack
just [ __ ] almost put a lumps in your
throat
for argentina it really does and i
really love i mean the use of music in
this is not really it's not arbitrary
particularly the
the very famous use of mad world which
uh
was originally by tears for fears in the
80s but actually the version that's in
this uh i think was by
gary jules or something like that it's
like a really like slow pretty like
acoustic version
because the lyrics of that song almost
match up
like exactly with the theme of this
movie yeah
though so that's why it was used now
this movie was made it came out in 2001
but it's actually set in 1988
this was the debut film of richard kelly
now this movie i feel like okay so
it premiered at sundance in early 2001
and then it
wasn't even gonna get a theatrical
release
i guess because they thought it was like
too weird or too indie or whatever
and so um i think that it was drew
barrymore's
production company she's in this like in
a small role it's all star cast actually
it really is yeah like everybody's in
this and it's a cute cast everybody's
good
it is everybody's good that's true first
movies
pretty much everybody's good looking in
the movie i just noticed it you know
watching it and it it really does even
though this is 91
2001 excuse me 2 000 watts when it came
out yeah it's a slip
even though it's [ __ ] 2001 when it
came out they
really did capture 1988 and i think i
guess it was because
that stuff was still around those kind
of clothes
and that yeah i mean you could find
normal [ __ ] sets or settings
that looked like 88 that [ __ ] was still
around it just
and the music and the way people had
their hair and just they're talking and
it's just like man that was it
and i liked too that it was set in 1988
but it wasn't
um like really self-referentially 80s
like look how 80s this is
it wasn't like that normal that's the
way it looked yeah it just looked like a
normal 80s
like setting which i thought was really
good yeah because a lot of people don't
realize that when you see these [ __ ]
b
movies from the 80s and that's not the
way people dressed they only dress that
way
yeah it's a little over the top yeah
over the top only in the movies
especially like all the punk rockers and
stuff like that that's way over the top
it was obvious to us in the 80s that
they were wearing costumes yeah
all right 80s costumes but that's not
the way people actually looked just
walking around it was more
the reality was a lot more soviet
looking real [ __ ]
kind of drab and boring and cheap off
the rack clothes that came from [ __ ]
walmart and sears and jay-z pennies
because people bought from [ __ ] malls
in those days and you didn't have much
selection
yeah quality wasn't that good yeah yeah
so yeah so this movie wasn't even going
to get a theatrical release but then
drew barrymore's company kind of stepped
up and they put it out in the theaters
it only got a very limited release and
it only and it came out
um in late october right after september
11th you know the month after and
because
there's a plot point in this involving a
falling jet engine
um they think that maybe that might have
been because they couldn't really
they didn't really want to advertise it
because they thought it would have been
in poor taste and [ __ ] like that because
people would have associated the two
things
so it didn't do all that well it didn't
really start
it kind of after that it sort of got it
got a limited release and then some
people started to see it and it started
getting a lot of like word of mouth
um like some theaters in the east
village in new york started doing like
midnight showings and they would start
getting sold out
sold out and so over time
it became like a cult sensation and by
the time that it came out like a
director's cut came out a couple of
years later in 2004 i believe
um it sold like 10 million dollars worth
of like
uh you know vhs or dvd or whatever
just because in the interim like its
reputation had built up so much so this
is another one of those movies that
was released in the theater didn't do
all that well and a lot of people didn't
see it but then like over time like word
of mouth made it into this massive cult
classic
i heard about it from goth girls yeah
yeah they were the ones that were
watching it well you guys see dying down
at arco you didn't see that you can see
dining dark is it now
so that that's where i first saw it and
and tell the truth i didn't understand
it they didn't understand it either i
don't think
well i it's just the vibe of that movie
it's hard to follow it what what's
happening
it takes i think it takes repeat
viewings and you have yeah
and it was the movie was way ahead of
its time for 2001. people weren't
weren't really used to the kind of
themes and the way
the way the [ __ ] story was structured
it was a weird movie
i do think that nowadays i mean because
people are still talking about it now
and still debating it now and there's
still
uh you know artwork based on it all this
other kind of stuff but like you said
this was really one of the first movies
i mean now we had like you know the
german tv series dark which we didn't
think about you had movies like looper
you had like primer like you
you have all these kind of like [ __ ]
up weird
time travel sort of things and people
understand it better i guess
isn't right loops and [ __ ] i mean this
was after the
was it 12 monkeys and even 12 monkeys
sometimes was i was kind of
in those days kind of reaching to
understand what was happening in
in in 12 monkeys it's not like you're
dumb it's just that
you're not used to stories those kind of
stories being told well time travel
is kind of um it's hard to wrap your
head around
in you know even for smart people so you
know you really have to like think about
it and like see the movie a few times
like to kind of figure out what's going
on and time travel stories
telling has evolved a lot i mean you can
go back to the 60s and look at that old
damn star trek
episode we saw where they accidentally
time traveled to the 1960s yeah
and they were using the teleporter the
transport the transporter
to [ __ ] fix some time [ __ ] it really
didn't make sense because they
because we were arguing about that i
said they put that pilot back in the
plane i'm like yeah but he would
remember all that [ __ ] right because
it's the same guy
yeah i mean when you when you move
backwards in time you also
move backwards you forget what happened
because that never happened see i'm not
sure
see i'm not sure if i buy that i think
that's what it would happen
because you've erased you've erased it
you didn't
you not only did you erase it from your
memory you erased it from the universe
so it never happened
you don't even remember i guess so
because that's what's happened in
other star trek i mean i guess it's all
theoretical they went back
it's not like anybody's right they
changed it they they went back and
changed the past
and they went through and like it didn't
even happen because it didn't happen
yeah they reversed it so nobody
remembered like remember
yeah even though it happened in their
future they haven't did a parallel
universe in their future they went back
and changed it never went through that
again
and we might kind of talk about that a
little bit when we talk about the end of
donnie darko because i
i don't know i don't know where i come
down on this but okay so
donnie darko i was actually one of the
few people i'm pretty sure i saw this in
the theater i mean i remember seeing
this in the theater and
this looks like something i would have
gone to see in 2001 because i was going
to a lot of movies in the theater then
and then i think i saw it again on cable
and then i watched it uh
yesterday on 2b now i will note that the
version that is for free on 2b right now
is the theatrical cut now the theatrical
cut
even though i didn't have a terribly
hard time following it i got the gist
um the theatrical cut leaves it a little
bit more ambiguous
over whether you're seeing you know an
actual
um you know time loop or time tangent
or whether donnie darko the character is
simply schizophrenic it leaves it
ambiguous however
the director's cut which came out in
2004
uh which actually goes much more into
the book that he receives that's written
by roberta sparrow which is called the
philosophy of time travel
pretty much explains exactly what
not exactly what's going on but
primarily like what is going on
in the story like what the roles of all
the people in the story are
so it makes it a lot clearer that yes
this is probably a time
tangent um you know it's i guess it's
still possible that it could be
you know just donnie imagining all of it
but i don't know i i
i can see that reading but it's just
that seems like a very unsatisfactory
uh reading for me because i like i like
the time travel aspect of it and i like
the time tangent aspect of it
so when you're just watching the
theatrical cut of the movie basically
what happens this is said on october 2nd
1988
there's a guy named donnie dark who is a
high school student kind of troubled you
know he's kind of been having a lot of
problems he's in a lot of medicaid
medication and stuff like that he gets
woken up in the middle of the night
by a voice that leads him out of his
house
now this voice belongs to a very
creepy six foot tall rabbit or a guy in
a rabbit suit a really creepy rabbit
suit
who tells him that the world is going to
end
in 28 days 6 hours 42 minutes and 12
seconds
donnie writes this on his arm he falls
back to sleep and he wakes up like on a
golf course he's been sleepwalking
when he returns to his house he
discovers that a wayward jet engine
has crashed into his house in his
bedroom
meaning that had he been there and not
been sleepwalking he would have been
killed however he wasn't because he was
out like the rest of his family are okay
now the interesting thing about this jet
engine is they don't really know
where the engine came from as in they
can't find any
plane that was you know that landed
without an engine or anything like that
so it seems like this engine
kind of came out of nowhere right so
this is a very uh
interesting and a very like a
significant plot point
now as the story goes on donnie either
depending on your reading of the movie
either becomes increasingly uh crazy
like uh you know schizophrenic seeing
visions
if thinking the world's gonna end [ __ ]
like that he keeps seeing frank the
rabbit everywhere
it keeps telling him to do [ __ ] like
um he goes to the school and uh you know
and busts a water main like with an axe
he floods the school
uh he sets this dude's house on fire he
starts like doing all these destructive
things
and under the influence of this rabbit
who's like telling him to do things
and starts to see things like water
streams like coming out of people's
chests that seem to be
um you know their paths in life and all
this other kind of stuff
so as this kind of stuff you see on lsd
yeah
yeah so so as i said now
and as this so as this you know goes on
you come to find out basically that
what's going on and this is another one
of those movies and i think i talked
about this when i talked about
mulholland drive
where pretty much every single thing in
this movie every single conversation
every single thing maybe not every
single thing that's maybe taken a little
too far but
most things in this movie have
significance
to what is happening in the story now in
the theatrical cut like i said as it
goes on and on
when we get to the end and he finally
realizes that
the time because it happens over a
28-day period which
coincidentally i don't know if this was
coincidental or not but
that's exactly how long it took to shoot
this movie 28 days so it's almost like
it was a one-to-one
which you can't i don't know so i don't
know if they did it on purpose but
whatever
so he starts to realize that the time
that frank told him
frank the rabbit that told him was the
end of the world was coming so he
decides well i have to go back to
roberta sparrow and ask her about
something
so he goes to the house they run into
some bullies it so happens that all of
these things
um take place that ends up with his
girlfriend gretchen getting run over by
a car and killed
and then he ends up shooting the driver
of the car that killed her who was
frank his sister's boyfriend who was
wearing the rabbit suit
and shooting him through the eye now one
scene earlier on in the movie
where he sees a vision of frank the
rabbit and frank takes his mask off he
sees that frank only has one eye like
this is
a wound in his eye he doesn't tell him
where it came from
so basically what you're figuring out is
that
this is the first time i watched it i
was like oh it's like a time loop
the first thing that i thought was that
donnie was supposed to be in his bed
when the jet engine fell because he was
supposed to die
and the fact that he didn't die set off
this other chain of events in which all
these other people got killed including
his girlfriend including frank
including his mom and his sister by
implication because they were on the
airplane that the jet engine came off of
however the more times that i watched it
and
after i saw the director's cut that's
not quite accurate we need to buy the
director's cut i want to see it again
yeah what is actually happening and some
and the directors cut
and there's like supplemental materials
too like for this is one of those movies
that
is like multimedia yeah um you know what
i mean
yeah kind of like [ __ ] prometheus
yeah that's where there's like a lot of
extraneous stuff
that uh you know so in the director's
cut they actually show you pages from
the
in universe book the philosophy of time
travel
now in this book basically what it lays
out
is that at some point before the jet
engine hit the house
okay a tangent universe was created
um the gen engine hitting the house
didn't make the tangent universe donnie
not being there that didn't make the
tangent universe there was no
real reason for the tangent universe i
guess or they're not telling you what
the reason is it was just like a random
occurrence
the jet engine was actually what is
called in the universe of the movie
an artifact now they do like kind of go
into this a little bit and the in the
theatrical cut where they say
um you know about an artifact having to
be made of metal like some [ __ ] made of
metal where he's talking to like the
science teacher about
a time machine how it has to be like a
metal object or something like that
so they're kind of they kind of go into
it a little bit but they go into it
clear in the director's cut
so the jet engine is an artifact which
signifies that a tangent
universe has been created so at the
point that the tangent universe was
created
the primary universe is paused
essentially because it's kind of gone
off on this other tangent
so basically the the entire bulk of the
movie until the very end
we are seeing the tangent universe this
is the universe that is not supposed to
happen
okay and like i said this is probably an
anomaly there's like no reason given for
it
or anything like that so the fact of the
jet engine falling in there like i said
that's the artifact
now the tangent universe as it says in
the book the philosophy of time travel
is too unstable to exist
and the jet engine does have something
to do with this because i think there
was
the tangent universe is like a copy of
the primary universe
and the there for some reason there was
like an extra jet engine
which is why when the jet engine hit the
house they didn't know like what plane
it came from because it didn't come from
anywhere it just kind of came from
well it actually ended up coming from
the future but you know that's kind of
like too complicated to get into
so basically the tangent universe can
only survive
for a couple of weeks because like i
said it's too unstable to keep existing
so when frank comes to donny and says
the world's going to end in 28 days blah
blah blah
he's correct uh the world is going to
end because the tangent universe is
going to collapse in on itself it's
going to collapse onto the primary
universe
causing a black hole which will wipe out
or potentially could wipe out all of
existence
so basically what the whole movie
is trying to do is trying to place
donny in the situation where he
can bring the jet engine
back from the tangent universe like back
into the primary universe
and i don't think he had to get killed
necessarily
but i think the reason of him getting
killed i think that's kind of like a
christ metaphor
because he kind of sacrificed himself
for everybody even though they don't but
nobody remembers it really
so donnie is what's known as the living
receiver now there's no particular
reason why he was chosen to be the
living receiver it's apparently just at
random because i guess this happens like
sometimes some people have argued that
roberta sparrow otherwise known as
grandma death in the movie
that she was a living receiver at some
point which is how she knew enough to
write the book philosophy of time travel
but that's you know kind of left up to
your imagination could be true maybe not
so donny is the living receiver now
everybody around him
are either the manipulated living or the
manipulated dead
manipulated dead are people that died in
the tangent universe
meaning frank because he got shot at the
end by donny
and gretchen um donny's girlfriend who
got run over by frank
they both died in the tangent universe
uh
so they they actually have extra special
powers
they are the ones frank is basically the
one that is leading donny
into like accepting his fate where he
has to go back
and use his powers as the living
receiver to pull
the jet engine using telekinesis uh
back into the primary universe and get
killed by the jet engine
so that all of the [ __ ] in the tangent
universe doesn't happen
okay um because if the tangent universe
like happens and it collapses and he
doesn't bring the jet engine back
then basically all of existence will be
wiped out
you understand what i'm saying yeah so
yeah it's like it's this is why i didn't
understand it there's a couple yeah it's
kind of complicated and like i said
i mean not really because there's a few
good videos on youtube where
um i can't remember i know nightmine did
one and a couple other uh
london city girls she's really good at
like describing she did a good one on
mulholland drive as well
i think that's her channel name um and
she has like a um
they have like a chart where they're
kind of showing you they're like here's
the primary universe which paused and
then it goes into this tangent
and then they show like how the jet
engine has to come back in there and
it's like a loop you know what i mean
and apparently like some people said if
donnie has to die like otherwise the
loop will repeat itself but i'm not
really sure
if that's the case or not because i
don't think there's any rule that says
the living receiver has to die
he just has to like bring the artifact
back into
the uh primary universe like you know
what i mean it's a creepy movie that's
all i know
it is trying to complicate it too much
no but that's exactly no that's what it
is because
like i said the in universe book
philosophy of time travel if you see the
director's cut
they enter they have like people reading
from it and this basically says exactly
this all right so everything that
happens
in the movie which is in the tangent
universe
everybody that you see um like
everything that happens in there is
almost like trying to cause a domino
effect
to get donny to the point where
he accepts his fate and
uses his powers because like i said as
the living receiver he also has like all
these powers he has
firepower water power telekinesis stuff
like that which they show during the
movie like not a big splashy way but
they show it
okay so in this parallel universe that
that the movie's taking place in yeah
does the real universe look the way
you're seeing it
in the [ __ ] movie like is that the
same neighborhood yes
it is the same area it's exactly the
same it's exactly the same
very upper except except there's an
extra jet engine
okay that's the only difference it's
almost like a mirror universe
it's like a mirror but it's exactly the
same other than i know maybe if you know
if what you're seeing in the movie is
actually the opposite of where it really
is like instead of it being in a
[ __ ] upper class neighborhood it's
actually happening in a lower class like
in like ghetto or something
no no it's exactly the same exactly all
right um and basically i think i'm
pretty sure that like the book says that
to you that it's just
it's just it's a perfect copy except
like i said this jet engine
was an extra component it was like a
glitch like a copying glitch
right and um so that was that was one of
the things that was making the tangent
universe
unstable even though the book implies
that all tangent universes are unstable
like i said it doesn't really give um a
reason why this tangent universe was
created it's just i guess this is a
thing that happens like every now and
then
and um whenever it happens an artifact
of some kind appears it's always made of
metal
and the only way that you can get rid of
the tangent universe and avoid it
collapsing in on the primary universe
and causing a black hole and wiping out
all of his
of existence is basically to go back in
time
like take the artifact back in time like
before the [ __ ] happened
i was just watching it i was having a
good time i was kind of like pook's the
cat
oh all right yeah but i didn't know what
i was seeing really
it was just creepy [ __ ] you know what i
mean it is a very creepy creepiness
of it was good enough i'm like okay all
right
well that's the cool thing the cool
thing about donnie darko and i think the
i mean it's one of those movies where if
you want to take a deep dive into and
you want to like figure it out and stuff
like that that is
there for you too yeah but it's a good
movie
even without that yeah like it's like
the characters are good like it has like
a really creepy atmosphere it has like
really
cool score and it's just like i know you
had to do
time travel yeah and you're in yeah it's
it's not a bunch of paranormal stuff you
know it's not like you can't
like it's incomprehensible like you
can't even from the theatrical cut
even from like a first viewing because
like even the first time i saw it not
even really know it was about or
anything like that
i got that it was some kind of time loop
and that he had to go back and like he
had to be under the jet engine so
so i got that it was that yeah when i
watch movies i'm not really trying to
think about it too much it's more like
escapism
i still enjoyed it that way though too
yeah well like i said trying to figure
it out
that's what's good about it is that it
can be enjoyed either way because
it's an enjoyable movie even if you
don't
like even if you're not trying to figure
it out you might not know exactly what
the deal is but like i said i think that
i think if you just know oh it's a time
loop i think that's enough
to yeah but then there was this [ __ ]
weird ghostly damn
rabbit guy got a suit that's pretty
weird too
like a kind of demonic i didn't really
figure that out it didn't i didn't
really have to it's just as [ __ ]
spooky
well frank yeah and then actually the
first time i saw it in the theater that
like really creeped me the [ __ ] out
well frank the rabbit he's not a ghost
not really
um he's a real person he's um he's
the uh he's donnie's sister's boyfriend
whose name actually is frank um on
october 30th
which is when frank gets killed he was
wearing that costume
okay um because that was a costume that
he made like to
a carnival now he gets killed by donny
because he ran over
uh the girlfriend and so the fact that
he was killed
in this tangent which wasn't supposed to
happen
allowed him to become the manipulated
dead and he could go
back in time to october seven second
and get donny out of bed so that he
wasn't in the bed when the jet engine
fell
so that he would be able to like
manipulate him all along the path
so that he would get to a point where he
could bring the jet engine back
and collapse the tangent okay so
everybody else everybody um so
manipulated dead like i said gretchen
the girlfriend she was also manipulated
dead because she died in the tangent
also like at the end
so she was kind of like she was there to
give donnie something to love because
one of his greatest fears which he told
his
therapist and everything was that he was
feared being alone or dying alone
so she was kind of there to give him
someone to love
and a motivation to kill frank which
would allow him to go back
now all the other people in the tangent
were what's called
manipulated living and they were kind of
all helping him along too so like
everything that happens in the movie
everything that everybody says to him
um you know every it you know it was
almost like a butterfly effect kind of
thing or like domino's falling because
you know one thing led to another thing
led to another thing until he got to the
point at the end
where he realized you know his
girlfriend was dead he had just shot a
guy
he didn't have anywhere else to go so he
finally accepted
i have to go back and die
you know get crushed by the jet engine
in order to
keep the world from ending because he
had read the book so he knew
what was going on now it should be noted
and i think i kind of like this reading
that at the very end
when he actually accepts his fate
and goes back into his house they go
back to october 2nd now the
when they go back to october 2nd the
donny that you're seeing
sleeping in the bed in his room like
before the jet engine hits
that's not the same donnie that's
primary universe donnie that's not
tangent donnie so there's still an
argument whether he knows that he's
about to die or not
because there's a shot of him and he's
sitting in bed and he's laughing
and then like he just lays down and goes
to sleep and then the jet engine falls
and kills him
so the implication being that he just
woke up from a dream
where he dreamed the whole tangent
universe [ __ ]
so we don't know how much of that he
knows or he remembers so i don't know if
he knows he's about to die
i kind of feel like he might be because
i think the whole point of the movie is
him just learning to
accept death and not be afraid of it
because there's kind of like this thread
with like patrick swayze's character
that you know getting over fear and like
conquering your fear
and he was um you know afraid of dying
afraid of being alone
so the fact of him you know getting to
that point where he can accept his own
death because he knows that it will save
everyone else in the world including the
girl he loves including his entire
family
um you know i think that that's kind of
like the whole theme of it
like i said there's almost well not even
almost there is kind of a religious
theme to it he's almost like a jesus
like a savior character the interesting
thing too is that
the final montage which they set um you
know
under that version of mad world which is
like really beautiful
they showed all the characters like
waking up from
dreams and being looking like kind of
troubled and stuff
implication being that all these people
were who were in the primary uh
universe remembered the tangent universe
um imperfectly because they had dreamed
about it
you know what i mean right so it was
still like you know they didn't live
through it because it didn't happen yet
and it wasn't going to happen but it
seemed real enough so they did
actually kind of remember donnie because
there's a scene at the end
where gretchen is riding past the darko
house on her bicycle now keep in mind
this is a primary universe so she has
not met donnie darko
yes she doesn't know who he is because
that just happened that whole thing
happened in the tangent universe
so she rides past on the house and sees
the jet engine like crash and they said
and she talks to this kid and he's like
uh she's like what happened and he's
like oh kid got killed there donnie
darko he was like at the high school and
and stuff and then she's like ah you
know that sucks or whatever
and then she looks at donnie darko's mom
who's like crying and like smoking a
cigarette
and kind of waves to her like she kind
of recognizes her
and then like the mom kind of recognizes
her back but not quite like they're just
kind of like man do i know you or
something like that
so there is that kind of thing where you
know even though
they didn't live through that [ __ ] they
still kind of remember it
like in a in the way that you would
remember a dream so it could be argued
too that donny might have only when he
woke up and he was laughing
he had just dreamed the whole tangent
[ __ ] too
so whether or not he actually knew that
he was gonna just get crushed by the jet
engine
and that that was gonna fix everything
um
like i said i think i do think that he
did know because i think that that makes
the
the theme of the movie more poignant i
guess
because he knew that he was sacrificing
himself to save the world
in some way this movie the tone of this
movie reminds me of another movie
that we reviewed called bavarium yeah
i was thinking that too when i was
re-watching this because i haven't
because i haven't seen this movie in a
long time like for many years if you
like
if you like done darkly probably like
bavarium and vice versa
i like the very i want to own that one i
want to own that on blu-ray yeah and
this is another one that i kind of want
like i said i want the director's cut
i've seen the director's cut once in the
theatrical cut twice
um like i said you don't really need to
see the director's cut
to kind of get the you know the gist of
what's going on but if you really want
to know kind of
more or less exactly what's going on you
probably need to see the director's cut
because it fills in
like a lot of stuff as i said the
theatrical cut you could read and i have
seen some people read it that it was
just
donny being a schizophrenic and he was
having like a schizophrenic break but
like i said what fun is that that's not
fun
you know what i mean it's much better
that it's
[ __ ] time travel that it's a [ __ ]
time you know but yeah so
anyway the theatrical version of this
movie is
available on to be for free to watch it
if you haven't seen it
i really do recommend it and this is one
of those movies that
just like mulholland drive i just i
could just read essays about it for like
hours and hours because i'm just
fascinated by
um the amount of work and thought that
go
into these types of movies where like
every single detail it seems like
has been you know engineered to like a
specific purpose and i'm like
really fascinated by that because i wish
my brain was that
uh that happens with a lot of uh
directors
yeah when they're young and they give a
[ __ ] about their trade and their
their first couple movies are something
that they have been working on for a
long
period of time and they got that [ __ ]
perfected on paper
before they ever started shooting the
movie yeah you can tell later on
how some like i've said before the shows
some of these directors after they
[ __ ]
have had a few failures and it knocks
the wind out of them they never really
quite come back
you know yeah sometimes it does seem
like well because your first movie is
probably the one you've taken
a lot not always but generally the one
you've taken the most care of
because it's what you know this is going
to be your debut and you think about it
and sometimes you've been working on it
for years and years
before you get the funding seems like
first four or five of any director
tend to be their best stuff after that
starts going downhill just like bands
yeah a band's first thrift two three
albums really
are are the yeah they're not always but
a lot of times
generally a lot of times it's you know
it it's for a for a band that's gonna
happen in those first
four to five albums you know you're
lucky if that band can come back and do
it a good
album five six seven you know very rare
yeah they usually run out of steam yep
and movies are like that so this is a
good
example of a guy who just comes out of
nowhere and [ __ ] makes a [ __ ]
mind-blowing little flick that
trips you out that people are still
talking about 19 years later
um i even said [ __ ] i even saw a picture
of a guy that had the exact tattoo
that donnie writes on his arm like with
marker about when the world's gonna end
he had it done exactly like that i will
note too
that there was a sort of sequel made to
this called
s darko which uh actually follows the
little girl samantha
who was in sparkle motion uh which you
know
i question your commitment to but um
those who have seen the movie will know
what i'm talking about but um yeah so it
follows her like when she's 18 years old
now i haven't seen it i have heard it's
not very good
and richard kelly who directed the
original donnie darko has
said look i've never seen it either i
didn't have anything to do with it i
don't want to see it
i don't even have the rights to the
donnie darko franchise anymore and
somebody else decided to make this
and i'm not happy about it so don't ask
me about it so he seems a little cranky
and probably rightfully so i mean i read
the wikipedia
um breakdown of it it sounds like it
would be okay but it sounds like just
kind of
it sounds like they tried to do the same
thing
except like with a meteorite instead of
a jet engine and like other things
and it sounds like it could have been
okay but it just seemed like more of the
same
i i do feel like when donnie darko came
out it was like so
original and i feel like any sequel is
just gonna be
like it's legendary like in the goth
dark wave scene
well yeah the old way of sin just
because the soundtrack setting and
everything
[ __ ] and the ideas it's you know if
you haven't seen it you're into that
kind of
if you're into that subculture then i
don't know what's wrong with you yeah
you must be young you must be a little
baby
i need to see donnie darko it's a trip
yeah i mean every it's one of those
movies that everyone should probably see
and like i said even if you you know
don't get into
the hole and you don't understand like
all the time tangent and everything like
that
it doesn't really matter like you can
still enjoy it it's still an intriguing
mystery it's still like at a creepy
atmosphere it's still got really good
acting really good character work and
stuff it's still got like funny moments
and things like that so it's still got
a lot of [ __ ] for me for me not
understanding all of it was actually
good now that you explained it i was
like oh that's all it was
well sometimes it's better to just kind
of leave it that's some weird [ __ ]
well like i said there are a couple
different readings of this like i said
you can read it as a jesus metaphor
you can read it as the times you can
read it as a schizophrenia
metaphor you can read it a couple
different ways although like i said i do
prefer the time travel thing and i do
think that that was
what richard kelly intended uh when he
made the movie i mean the fact that
when he came out with the director's cut
he put like the text of the book and
like it's
all the [ __ ] that it said in there it
was definitely you know time
loops and parallel dimensions yeah
alternate universes that's
definitely that yeah uh the whole rabbit
thing kind of had a weird
it did seem like he was dealing with the
spirit world too well that guy
the fact that he got killed in the
tangent that means like i said that
means that he
was a manipulated dead and that gave him
special powers
right so he could actually go back in
time and
you know help donnie do this and he
could do like a cool paranormal [ __ ]
donnie could do paranormal [ __ ] too
because he was the living receiver soul
energy [ __ ] the
kind of like the dead uh kind of ghost
ghostly phenomenon some almost poultry
guys phenomenon telekinesis that kind of
stuff
and it was there was a lot of stuff in
there about god and about
fate and um you know so you know
the whole thing the whole discussion
that he had the science teacher the
whole thing that he sees
of you know the stuff coming out of
people's chests which is like their life
path
like he could see it you know what i
mean in like people's destinies and
things like that
so there was a lot of that in there too
like i said it's not overtly religious
but it does kind of go into
um you know how fate works how destiny
works like if you can
change it if he can manipulate it if he
can do stuff like that the whole
life path thing the damn ghostly [ __ ]
clear thing coming out of the chest that
reminded me of one time
we were in high school we got really we
took a bunch of [ __ ] lsd
i just did like three like three hits of
that damn [ __ ]
that is a lot of pain and we went to
denny's we drove to denny's
that's what it was like back in the
[ __ ] what did the moons over miami
look like on lsd
and we noticed that there was a [ __ ]
glare
like a rod of white kind of glare coming
off the top of everybody's head going up
into the ceiling we could all see it you
see
you see it yeah it's like a [ __ ]
spike going up and we realized that
that was the part of them that went into
the higher universe where everyone comes
from and that we're
all connected from yeah that's how we
saw it as that's what we thought it was
that is one thing that lsd does it does
make you feel like
yeah like you're like everyone's
connected to everything interconnected
right yes
yeah which is it's funny because until i
took it myself i was like oh that's what
all those hippies are talking about yeah
yeah
that's exactly what it feels yeah we
thought that it was like kind of like
the uh the astral cord type of situation
right
going up into a higher dimension and in
that dimension
all those lines intersect and everyone's
connected into one thing it's kind of
like a
a universal consciousness that's what we
saw you know because you get all
[ __ ] metaphysical and [ __ ] you get
all supernatural
yeah when you're on a lot of acid if
it's good
you get all joe rogan joe rogan in his
dmt
yeah yeah but yeah seriously this this
movie would actually probably
i mean it's good the way it is but it
would probably benefit with uh you know
some lsd or some weed
yeah so you can like think about all the
philosophical implications of it because
like i said there's a lot of [ __ ] to
unpack in this it's very
layered and like i said every single
pretty much every single scene every
single conversation or something like
that
has significance like to the greater
theme and i just
i love movies like that i'm like you
know because i'm a writer i guess and so
i
just like have this you know really like
i really admire like writers that can
that can do something that complex and
like pull it off
and like i said still talking about
donnie darko nowadays and this was
this was the movie that won the poll so
hopefully
we did it justice yeah he did it justice
thank you
i'm getting sleepy i gotta take my old
man nap well you better you can't nap
too much because we gotta do another
live stream
a little while so you can't get too much
people like sleeping in the middle of
the day i don't
understand i can't sleep for the middle
of the day because you're not an old
lying like me
i wish i could but i can't i got too
much [ __ ] i got
to sleep uh but yeah so just remember uh
this
video will go up thursday for the
patrons friday for uh the public
and remember to go if you're a patron
remember go back and i'm going to start
doing it every friday
i'm going to start posting polls of what
movie you want to see for the following
week what topic you want to see in the
following week so everybody got to go
vote so i can figure out
what [ __ ] we're gonna review alright so
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you
on the next one bye